most people die at 25 and aren't buried
until they're 75. why 0 to 25 and you
kind of progress up like a beautiful
Milestone every single year all of a
sudden at 25 those Milestones just
become marriage mortgage kids funerals
of loved ones and then your own funeral
reasons why I think it happens is one
lack of Milestones institutionalization
institutionalization because people go
from the education system where they
kind of sat there all day for 18 years
asking to go to the toilet and then they
just got thrown out in the wild like a
prisoner and as a result people really
struggle to adapt to that you go from
having your caregivers there your entire
life supporting you all of a sudden one
day you get a phone call and you're
their caregiver or they're not even here
so it just immediately switches on you a
few solutions for that which is one
create regular Milestones I'll try and
split the year into quarters now which
is enough time to Sprint up things so
then you have like four Milestones per
year to try and schedule things in with
friends regularly family regularly three
I think we also have a lack of religion
in current Society those regular rituals
a thing bigger than you that you're
working on so important to have and you
can then begin to not die at 25